[Musique]
nous
au milieu des champs dans une petite
communauté du nord de l'alberta
une centaine de familles tentent de
maintenir leurs traditions les russes
comme on les appelle ici sont des vieux
croyants vieux parce qu'ils n'ont
toujours pas accepté que leur église
l'église orthodoxe se modernise au xviie
siècle
leur mode de vie ils ressemblent encore
à celui de leurs ancêtres
le jeune le mercredi et le vendredi la
lecture de vieux livres saints les
vêtements longs pour les femmes
tout ça pour garder le christianisme
dans sa forme la plus pure
foster finira cousine sauf travail dans
cette boutique où les femmes viennent
acheter tissus et dentelle pour
confectionner leurs robes sur les
cheveux elle porte un foulard assorti il
cherche mourras quand une femme se marie
en lui mais ce bandeau sur la tête
certaines femmes l'enlève la nuit mais
moi je me sens plus en sécurité quand je
le porte
m fina a 19 ans et elle s'est mariée il
ya neuf mois
je connais mon mari depuis que j'ai 11
ans avant notre mariage on pouvait
s'embrasser mais il reste ce n'était pas
permis mais comment ces vieilles
traditions orthodoxes ont-elles pu
s'implanter à plamondon petit village
pourtant fondée par des francophones
mon vieux croyants longtemps persécutée
en russie ont fui leur pays par milliers
après la révolution de 1917 ce sont
d'abord réfugié en chine puis au brésil
dans les années 60 70
les centaines de familles ont pris le
chemin de l'orégon de l'alaska ou de
l'alberta en quête de travail y
d'isolement cherchait de bonnes terres
agricoles loin des villes pour qu'ils
puissent pratiquer leur religion un
retrait lui c'est avait le routeur ses
parents qui ont émigré à plamondon était
fermier et comme bien des hommes de sa
génération pavel a voulu profiter des
occasions qui s'offraient à lui au
canada
il a choisi de se lancer en affaires
dans notre religion il ya 21 jours c'est
où
fermer boutique en plus dès dimanche
mais comme je possède mon entreprise de
construction
je peux contrôler mon horaire c'est pour
ça que j'ai choisi ce métier
le routeur aussi ouvert une
microbrasserie qu'il gère avec son fils
une démarche qui aurait été impensable
chez les vieux croyants il ya quelques
dizaines d'années c'est ce qu'on est
influencé par la société accidentelle
est pour nous c'est de plus en plus
difficile de maintenir notre culture est
déjà en quelques décennies les
changements sont fulgurants dans les
années 80 les vieux croyants n'aurait
jamais permis à des non pratiquants
d'entrer chez eux ou partager la même
vaisselle dans ma classe
j'avais russe et au pic est enseignée à
l'école publique de plamondon à cette
époque ce qu'il a vu avec quoi on se
quitte plus d'un on à s'éteindre
mais aujourd'hui ce n'est plus le cas et
les élèves d'origine russe complètent
leur secondaire est ce qui inquiète dans
la communauté
c'est que les jeunes maîtrisent de moins
en moins la langue d'origine
même si l'école offre 35 minutes de
cours de reçus chaque jour ils parlent
souvent anglais entre eux
pavel routeur j'espère que la prochaine
génération saura comme lui se moderniser
tout en maintenant certaines traditions
nos grands parents se sont tellement
battu pour qu'on puisse vivre notre
religion en paix
pour finir vos questions baisser les
bras c'est dans cet univers que je me
sens en sécurité
[Musique]